we have another winner of today's round
christopher yu defeating my student
jamiljan ali marandi christopher how'd
that game feel
uh very good i definitely did not expect
to win that position
it felt like he won the battle in the
opening after that you guys transitioned
into more or less balanced end game but
you still had that extra pawn were you
still thinking that you could
potentially turn that into a victory
yeah um i didn't expect to get the extra
pawn so i was very excited when he just
gifted me the extra pawn kind of very
unnecessarily let's actually pull that
uh
on the screen right there around here
yeah
yes
yes he goes when did you feel like uh
you're gaining the advantage you're
breaking through let's say
not here
i thought if like anybody was playing
for the win it would be him but
knight f6 was the first confusing
decision for me it didn't seem necessary
to just give up the c7 pawn but i
wouldn't really consider it a mistake
and after knight e4
f3
i think he should have won knight f2
because he's threatening knight h3
knight f2 with a draw some sort of a
perpetual right now and if you try to go
to g2 knight to g4 seems to be
quite uh quite strong
yeah yeah what were you uh
what were you preparing to do after
knight to f2
um
maybe just knight b5 and let him take a
draw and just accept the draw i i don't
see anything better yeah right but he
won knight c5 and it feels like he over
pushed a position i really didn't like
him pushing your king all the way to g3
i didn't understand that at all
yeah i think he might have missed that
after rick d3 i have worked a free route
takes a free knight takes a free knight
takes a4 knight c4
i think he might have saw today
it was just a dead draw with king after
rook detours even this should be a draw
right not that but you should be able to
draw yeah i think this is like better
than what he got in the game in the game
right
because it felt like this end game we
mentioned this on air this move f5 was
very important it felt that this gave
you the greatest amount of winning
chances yeah
and where do you think the decisive
mistake came because we also felt this
one maybe still can be held
where did the final mistake come
maybe you should have tried to put this
pawn on f5 to
stop my pawns from moving a little a
little bit
once i got my pawn on f5 and my knight
on f4 like this weak f6 and h5 pawn
he couldn't really manage
the situation
right he did a beautiful job there
controlling his knight
not allowing him any counter play and
once the king reaches here
you cannot defend all your opponents
unit defend any of your pawns and you
convert it quite nicely it just seems
like you make a mistake against
christopher you and you're just gonna go
down
yeah at least today
well two victories christopher two draws
no defeats how do you feel uh about your
performance after this point
very good
no complaints no complaints it is well
always uh to see you doing well here in
the studio christopher thank you very
much and good luck in the rest of your
game thank you all right let's catch up